l'actualité c'est aussi la fête de
l'internet qui se déroule jusqu'à
dimanche aujourd'hui on considère que
cinq millions de français surf sur le
web pour capter l'intérêt des
internautes les sites ont tendance à
développer des animations de qualité sur
leur page d'accueil
et c'est dans la région de lille que
l'on trouve les meilleurs créateurs de
films d'animation un festival a même été
créée reportage marianne masse patrick
d'un stop
ils étaient deux ils sont 18
il était logé tout petits ils viennent
d'investir une ancienne usine textile
c'était hier c'est demain l'histoire de
schumann une petite start up de
production de jeux et programmes pour le
web cette semaine pour fêter l'internet
ils ont invité des designers du monde
entier
alors pour nous c'est pas moi je suis
allemand leur mission créée pendant 24
heures non-stop le plus beau site web du
monde sur le thème du commerce
électronique
juste pour s'amuser mais derrière
l'apparenté décontraction et la moyenne
d'âge de 25 ans il y a aussi les
affaires concrètes du contenu et on le
vend les diffuseurs
donc c'est une économie qui est nouvelle
pour internet puisque en fait tous
clients sont à la fois déjà en france
comme des gens à l'étranger aux états
unis en asie qui nous achètent comme il
le ferait une chaîne télévisée une
assiette des programmes pour le diffuser
sur leur site un dessin animé en
plusieurs épisodes jeux interactifs des
animations qui vont fidéliser les
utilisateurs du site et donc le faire
acheter éventuellement ici les web
designers sont en train de créer la
culture internet c'est ce qu'imaginent
le contenu de divertissement de main ce
qu'ils vont nous avons télé jeux ces
petits films qu'on va voir sur notre
téléphone cellulaire ou dans nos télés
interactive donc sans train d'inventer
quelque part nous nous fixions de man
une forme de création qui a déjà son
festival et ça n'est pas un hasard s'il
a lieu à lille en quelques années le
nord est devenu un pôle majeur de
production multimédia
il ya des entreprises ils étaient 2 il
ya deux ans ils sont 50 donc là vraiment
on parle d'emploi en parle de dizaines
d'emplois et les
les développements futurs et on les
connaît sur certains dossiers on parle
de centaines d'emplois d'ici un ou deux
ans les récompenses seront décernées ce
soir à l'occasion du début de la fête
d'internet partout en france
le